please to have here for the very first
time from Watchmen on HBO which is just
a red-hot hit right now a gentleman
whose careers as the kids would say
blowing up hey there might be a spoiler
we're trying not to spoil anything but
that's the way Watchmen rolls Yaya Abdul
Mateen the second good to see you sir
thank you so much I'm glad to be here
what's life like for you right now I'm
chilling man the show that you are on
yeah yes absolutely exploding dance
great man it's nice to be a part of
something that's culturally relevant you
know that's in the zeitgeist I'm having
a really good time looking at the
conversation on Twitter you know I'm
having a really good time watching my
family and everybody react to what I'm
sort of in the middle of it just kind of
hanging out but yeah all the buzz and
all the energy around it has been has
been pretty awesome well I mean you
can't tell your family what's going on
right I mean you can't reveal your like
lending them your you're letting them
learn it just as yeah oh yeah oh yeah
definitely bit low yeah yeah I don't
want to rob them of that of that
experience right exactly and in the last
two weeks your character has had quite a
change quite yeah yeah and I just I
guess I'll leave it up to you what you
want to throw out there we just did see
you in a in a senior which is this so I
mean if you you know if if you've seen
it then you already know that my
character was revealed to be dr.
Manhattan the most powerful being in the
you know in the history of the comic
canon really and he has been awesome man
I signed up to play one character
thinking that I was gonna go and play
Regina King's husband yes you know that
stay-at-home dad and and that's uh that
was like an awesome opportunity in and
of itself and then it turned out to be
something that was uh that was much much
much much more that's actually just
talked about Regina King and the in the
television only second here I can't I
can't love that woman anymore
she's a news and he was like a fan yet
huge like a fan I had a lot of fun last
year giving her a lot of a lot of flack
for uh well you hope you got it in while
you come because you're a warrior fan
and the the universe is kind of flipped
here oh you know I'm uh I just wanted to
get you know get it out I'm a Shaq fan
huge huge huge Shaq fan why is that I
just wanted to be seven-foot taught me
it was Shaq it was you know
Shazaam and and and he was the man who
knows that when I was groans to pray to
be seven feet tall so I could be just
like Shaquille O'Neal right and so I
follow Shaq to the Lakers I follow Shaq
to the heat and then once I started to
go on his on his tour then I started you
know chilling out with Kobe you know for
a little while and after coke we retired
I was just a fan of really good
basketball so I am mandated to say just
as somebody who's in this position
uh-huh and I do love Shack and he would
think would want me to point out there's
a big difference between Shazam and
Kazaam close to the DC property totally
different totally creature you look
you're also from the New Orleans area
Roddy from born okay yeah born in New
Orleans raised in Oakland California so
that's that's how I get the golden state
of connection but also the the 49ers in
the in the in the Saints connection also
what was again I know you might be busy
stuff going on obviously I have your
future projects here and one title after
the other just sleeps off yeah
leaps off the page here but Saints and
Niners playing each other last Sunday
that was a good football game it sure
was I was uh I was at the 40/40 club
with a lot of friends everybody was from
New Orleans Saints fans don't play that
means Saints fans just do not play
that's correct
about the football and and and you know
I was in there and I'm the only 49er fan
in there so you're rooting so when it
comes to it uh-huh
game on the line season on the line
they're playing each other you're you're
leaning towards the 49ers over the
Saints I'm leaning toward the 49ers over
the Saints in a scenario where the 49ers
are playing the Saints okay independent
of that yes I'm really hoping that the
Saints go all the way except for this
path
Sunday except for this past Sunday okay
so when the chips are on because it you
know I mean the path to the Super Bowl
yeah made easiest by having home field
throughout this is true and now the
Niners have that the Saints done yeah
that's true the Saints gonna have to
slug it out but this ice lost me I mean
but the 49ers lost me honestly with the
Chip Kelly hire because you know it's
interesting my opinion he kind of blew
up the you know the team in Philly went
to San Francisco I thought he was just
gonna do the same thing I was a horrible
guy I really like you know what you know
what Harbaugh was doing over there I
knew I liked it uh and then uh you know
once chip came in I was like yeah I
think I think that was to get past the
Jim Tomsula yeah at all yes to try and
change the page yah yah yah yah yah yah
abdullah ii right here in the Rich Eisen
show so but is this maybe your cow roots
coming out here that you didn't like an
Oregon guy go bears all day so now you
went to Cal right you got Cal Berkeley
and you ran Trevor it's right okay let
it attract what you do 110 hurdles 400
hurdles and I tried a triple jump and a
meet against uh against Washington oh
yeah I guess Waseem tried yeah I did
yeah I tried you I probably took like 44
or something like that and then and
that's insane Wow
so you had a terrific career as a track
star I mean I would have I think I had
and I stuck to it I was fun I was uh I
was very very good in a high school and
went to Berkeley ran track for two years
and then the architects were track
didn't mix I studied architecture also
and so I ended up not running a track
anymore and focusing on architecture so
how did you get into acting I honestly I
was doing a skit for the for the team
and track yeah for the track team it was
like a team-building exercise where the
all the underclassmen had to perform for
the upperclassmen went on stage and I'm
doing impressions of impersonations of
the coaches and everybody's cracking up
laughing next day I practice were
warming up and we're stretching and my
teammate JP he said
almost verbatim he says dude you should
take a theater class it's just like
recess and I'm like oh the theater class
recess eza I'm after it you know a
mathuroth and that's that's where the C
was born okay yeah that's where the C
was born and so what was your first big
break then would you say my first big
break was my first job but in 2015 well
I got I got laid off so getting laid off
was my first big from what some uh my
city planning job because I I pursued
the architecture path I ended up working
in San Francisco at the mayor's office
of housing I got laid off in 2000 2010
and I said man I'm gonna go just do
something I'm you know go try to have
some fun I had my unemployment coming in
so I didn't really have to worry about
okay paying so much of my share of the
rent you know with my brother and that
kind of just rolled into me getting into
a play and learning that I can go to
graduate school once it went to Yale
studied acting for three years and I got
my second break on a show called to get
down on Netflix that was 2015 right yah
yah yah Abdul Mateen the second here on
the Rich Eisen show now my kids don't
know you from Watchmen
uh okay my kids are 11 yeah six uh-huh
the greatest show the greatest showmen
is a whole different ball yeah man what
an amazing yeah film yeah man that is
yeah just awesome yeah soup to nuts the
whole thing what was it like for you on
that set and for that film I went to try
preschool for for two months you know
what I mean and I go from I go from like
this disco dancing you know kingpin in
1970s New York to wearing all purple
spandex and singing about you know
acceptance and singing about being a
beer being and you know an individual
and things like that and that was wild
man you know it was it was literally
like a circus literally yeah like a
circus and I'm dancing with this you
know they had that some the greatest
dancers in the world and then Hugh
Jackman you know I was in jail
yeah Hugh Jackman's and daya Zac Ephron
I mean all over the place it was just
it's a completely completely different
world but I've been able to have really
good to be being really good company man
that the music in that yeah in that film
you see I sing Sinatra okay cuz that's
my although I have tried to I do sing a
million dreams with my kids okay I'm not
just a face I will sing the I'll try to
do the lower register if I go higher
register I got no okay yeah but I out
that I sing all those songs are amazing
oh they're amazing and so you saw the
film with your family or attempted to
write which one greatest showmen when
you try to take your family to the film
well I can only take so many because you
know really big family so I think maybe
one of my says maybe one or only one or
two of my sisters came to that premiere
okay yeah yeah yeah but then going to a
theater it was all sold out or something
like that
Oh in New Orleans when I went to go take
the family there yeah and that was I
mean that was that was that was pretty
cool you know I took him to the theater
uh it was uh it was all sold out was it
from your neighborhood where you grew up
or something like that yeah it was this
uptown uptown just you know just went to
the theater and we go there and I'm
thinking that you know hey we're gonna
come see me in this movie and it's all
sold out and you know I take it you know
I take away right you know you take the
win my movie sold out so now we go go
okay now we have some seafood or
something like that
all right and then go back a little bit
later so again you're you're you're used
to having something that you've done
become culturally iconic and then
blowing up I mean so that's what the
greatest showman you were in that film
and yeah now you're in Watchmen so let's
discuss this a little bit here yeah
because it was just revealed you're
literally portraying dr. Manhattan just
literally like a god and turning what
was the most difficult part of the
transformation for you as an actor to to
become this blue God spoiler alert
everybody uh well the acting was was was
one part of it he's a guy who's not
super emotional so I wanted to focus on
like how to make him
God but also make him human I didn't
want him just to just be be a robot but
I also didn't want him to be too human
that was one side of it but the getting
in shape for that role was just I'm not
a guy who I mean I will get in shape but
I'm not gonna get up and go to the gym
on my own you know it's like it takes a
job to get me in the gym religiously so
you know I thought I put on some muscle
I had to eat right in and get ready
because you definitely don't want a guy
like that to show up not looking the
part you know to show up out of shape I
know you're in tracking country you
eating pizzas when you're on the track
team but I was nineteen nineteen and you
know 19 and 20 years old and so you know
you can kind of you can kind of do it
like that you know what I mean how old
are you now I'm 33 okay yes and now
you're 33 and you gotta you gotta
actually put some time in the gym for
this source yeah yeah you got it you
know you got a you got to look the part
and I keep doing these jobs where I got
to get in shape man Aquaman and now I'm
doing the matrix in you know watch me
and I keep one would think that I would
just get in shape and stay in shape
right but I won't learn my lesson love
your life I love the offseason man this
I love the offseason
what are you indulging in the offseason
where are you going the uh I love play
well I still love playing basketball
okay I play bass I'll try to play
basketball once a week tell me about
your game uh you know I told you that I
grew up looking up to Shaq yeah so that
means you don't shoot free throws well
no reason I love the bangs man I love
the bangs
okay bein down low but also you know big
men still think that their guards too so
you know I'll still I still take up the
ball like you know like Shaq in the
all-star game okay yeah
you're six-two six-three what are you
I'm I like to say that I'm 63 if you let
me have that I'll take I will if you let
me be six feet okay yeah okay we're got
that so let's just let's just this is
the Yaya Abdul Mateen the second I guess
run down here okay three yep you're 6 3
& 0 1 2 oh wow okay I will put down 201
and your your game is your down low
I like to go I'm a I'm a I'm a three
guard I'm a three guard who can bang do
they still make three guards anymore
Chris you play regularly what do you
have if you're free on Tuesdays we could
use you okay small forward everyone kind
of shoots threes now there everyone
she's now I saw taco fall shooting
threes that's nonsense
I saw taco for warming up shooting
threes he said before one of the Boston
games he's he's seven five and a half
the hotel led to him he'll tell him that
thirty seven six so so what is your so
you you can reign from three as well I
mean I can I will suit well here trying
to make a play to get into the NBA
all-star game celebrity game is this
what you would you be in yeah if there
was like NBA all-star game like a
celebrity duck contest or something like
that chunk yeah I get it I get it
I could John right now I can jump now
we're not talking about here with John
is you I've got the footage you can Ju
you have don't know I'm sure you can I
mean there's a ditch so what are you
going windmilling what are we doing for
you you can windmill I got a window for
you yeah I got about got video footage
of a women for you we're are line here
is when we don't mean to be saying
anything respectful but trying to get
away from somebody to see the feels long
as you just front your statement with
with all due respect you say anything
you are okay with all due respect we're
gonna be see the footage of the window
I love it I love it
so the finales this weekend what can you
tell us about it man we try to elevate
the show and give you something to watch
every single week episode 8 was a was a
hard-hitting banger and there's you know
there's a lot of plot to cover a lot of
ground to cover in episode 9 so it's uh
it's ambitious and I think it's gonna I
think I think we step up to the plate I
just have have all your surprises been
taken care of can you you know I think
that they I think there's definitely
more surprises to I mean they come gosh
yeah that's great and you didn't mention
some of your next projects oh yeah so
let's let's get into it
a Candy Man a sequel to the 92 film
Candy Man got out in June 2020 I've
heard of the guy who was written that
his name is Jordan Peele yep
awesome awesome okay yeah so dope to be
a part of that and also bringing back
the iconography of Candyman yeah you
know even even for people who don't know
the plot of that movie they still know
like candy man you just don't don't mess
with candy man you know what I mean so
it's it really could be bringing
something like that back and to be
bringing it in at a time you know that's
you know we're making something's gonna
be culturally relevant you know coming
out of you know Jordan peels head and
and coming out of his head yeah yeah
next time I think that's gonna be dope I
bet yeah
the trial of Chicago's of the Chicago
seven yeah heard of the writer and
director his name is Aaron yeah yeah
yeah and you play Bobby Seale that's his
role yeah
Oakland cat you know Black Panther Bobby
Seale this is the trial where he was
notoriously uh the the notorious trial
where he was a bound and gagged for
three days in the courtroom for you know
speaking out for himself so that's a
that's a different kind of drama you
know important important you know is
this is a film about speaking up and
about getting out there using your voice
and you know putting yourselves in your
you know your body on a lot for for
calls that Cass and Sheree Sacha Baron
Cohen and red meat very strong
and Joseph gordon-levitt yep yep and you
yep Yaya Abdul Mattie in the second love
why you keep on saying my name and let's
do it well you know what it is it's also
the radio on yeah yeah resetting for the
audience Phil you are yeah yeah sitting
here next to me just in case they don't
know you're also an Aquaman 2 in matrix
4 I've heard of all these films my gosh
man yeah man now what can you say about
these films man I forget about them all
the time because of always I'm working
on one thing but I'm excited for it man
I got a really good slate coming up for
the next couple of years and it's gonna
be really excited it's nice that I got a
good mix of like the big movies and then
you know the small independent things
that matter also so I got a really good
mix I'm just trying to work on really
just work on my game and work on and
work on having a having a place to stay
you know now your game is basketball
that's what I'm saying yeah yeah yeah
cuz your windmill dunking yeah I can do
that the NBA all-star game for celebrity
okay yeah given the chance given
attention you will do this yes I will do
that and you see you know what and if
you're there you can interview me first
you know what I would be all over that
certainly since we just saw from your
future project you only work for people
with Oscars so you know I will take that
assignment yeah you know I mean your
tongue a windmill just so from the
free-throw line like Jordan I mean
what's your best dunk give me like if
you got to go with your best dunk what
is your best my best dunk yes like you
got your go-to dunk you know the whole
world is watching and you've got a jam
that thing in you know what do you got I
think I think I think I think the
windmill is the one I think the windmill
is I don't have I don't have several
dunks okay but I'm a guy that you got to
look out for on the rebound like a
Caruso you know yeah okay you know mean
you got to look out for that guy now you
know I just compared myself to all the
losers for you to compare yourself to
LeBron or something like that
you know honestly talking about David
Caruso from CSI
unexpected because it's unexpected and
it's unexpected because I'm an actor and
he can I just can't ball you don't mean
it gets LeBron off the bench because
usually LeBrons well out of the game you
just want that moment already catch some
flack for it by their - I love it well
Congrats on everything going on no thank
you I appreciate come back anytime yeah
I appreciate you got it come on singing
that footage you will it's called
content yeah yeah Abdul Mateen the
second you can follow him at Yahya on
both Twitter and Instagram why a hya
check out the watchman's season finale
coming up Sunday on HBO great to see her
he said we gotta we're back with more in
a second thanks it was for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app